these are
live shots from balmoral apologies for
the quality we think we're just getting
the link established um but you see
members of the royal family there
who have been attending that service uh
let's just uh listen in they're speaking
to well wishes
[Music]
[Music]
how are the pictures breaking up ever so
slightly but you can see prince andrew
uh leading uh senior members of the
royal family uh princess anne uh there
as well prince edward sophie wessex greg
milam is there at balmoral and greg we
did expect this to happen so many people
are coming down to balmoral to pay their
respects to the queen and this is what
they wanted to see they wanted to see
members of the royal family
yeah and i think we've learned over the
years haven't we um how how much uh
these crowds appreciate this this this
personal touch if you like this this
personal moment with members of the
royal family and and of course we
haven't seen
those other members of the royal family
in public since thursday and what
happened but we do now
see them see them here
and and that private moment of the
service at the crafty church which is so
dear to the royal family
but now this this public moment if you
like of taking time to talk to those who
are here uh but also to to view those uh
tributes that have been laid see the
princess royal uh her children zara
tindall and peter phillips her husband
commander
tim lawrence
leading that that group who have walked
from crafty church the
earl encounters of wessex as well
and princesses beatrice and eugenie with
the with the duke of york um
and just
exchanging a few words with those who
are among the hundreds who've made this
journey down
hey
okay
yes
which
what
uh
so
well it was the queen he said grief is
the price you pay for love and as a
nation mourns so do her family